executive presence or EP is simply what
you signal to the world what you
Telegraph to the world in terms of first
are your gravitas do you really know
your stuff cold do you give the
impression that you're three questions
deep you know in your field of expertise
perhaps do you have intellectual
horsepower how do you signal that that's
the gravitas piece secondly do you have
really serious communication skills can
you get your ideas across I mean can you
be heard because no matter how profound
your gravitas if you can't somehow you
know get it across it becomes dead in
the water and then finally presentation
of self the way you dress your body
movement the way you stand and walk all
of this incredibly critical in allowing
your gravitas again to get across so the
great thing about you know this piece of
work
we went out to 4,000 professionals
around the u.s. in all kinds of
different sectors and 300 leaders it was
a representative sample so we do know
what our colleagues and what our bosses
are really looking for on this front and
it's fascinating because it turns out
there really is almost a checklist out
there that we can work with a much of
this is very learn about there were two
reasons why I wrote this book first off
at my think tank we had discovered three
years ago that the main reason that
women aren't making it into top jobs is
that they don't get sponsors they have a
ton of mentors but they don't have this
you know senior advocate who really goes
out on a limb for them so why are they
not chosen as potential porridges and
groom for leadership and we found that
many many male leaders around the
country saw women as
lacking executive presence somehow they
weren't signaling that they were
leadership material well they weren't
ready for the big opportunity so we
wanted to look at executive presence to
see what in fact this was and how we can
all crack it but I think the other root
of this book is much more personal I
grew up in the South Wales coal mining
valleys I was one of six girls in an
industrial Valley which was you know
really rather dig lected in the 1960s
and 1970s the unemployment rate was 38
percent and I remember really
understanding you know how bleak how few
opportunities you know this environment
really was and so when I was 13 my
father who was trying to do something
with his girls despite the fact he was
very much a working-class bloke took me
by bus to Cambridge University and kind
of fired me up about you know the
possibilities of perhaps going to this
amazingly beautiful campus which was you
know one of the best universities in
Europe and he was very audacious I mean
he he turned around to me and said you
know girl he tended to get our names
mixed up so he called a lot of us girl
he said if you work hard you can go here
and I went back to Wales to my you know
really rather mediocre school and did
work incredibly hard and did get in but
when I got to Cambridge at age 18 I was
really like a fish out of water and the
main thing that got in the way I mean I
was you know a good student I was good
at passing exams but every time I open
my mouth I let myself down it was so
hard to feel like a success story at
Cambridge or I suspected anyplace else
if you spoke English the way I did I had
a very thick working-class Welsh accent
I dropped my h's I mispronounced a lot
of words and you know my tutor at
Cambridge said that I simply sounded
uncouth
word still sticks in my mind and I
realized I had up my game on the
communication front otherwise I would
get nowhere
so I spent two years listening to the
BBC World Service trying to you know get
those modulated vowels down and also
fixed by grammar and it made a massive
difference I felt that I could then you
know get my ideas across I could get my
voice heard and so I think you know that
experience made me very interested in
this whole field you know signalling
that you're the real deal is about how
you act how you speak how you look it's
about gravitas is about communication
and inspire appearance and oftentimes we
underrate you know these qualities
because these things do not seem to be
about performance they do not seem to be
about whether we achieve the goals that
we are you know tasked with in the
workplace but they make a huge
difference in terms of whether you're
the person who's chosen for that next
job or that next big opportunity